You've just learned how to
protect yourself from syntax and
coding style issues.
But as you know, this doesn't ensure
your code does what it's supposed to do.
In order to test the functionality of
your code, you should create unit tests.
Unit tests are essentially JavaScript
functions that pragmatically test an API
or aspect of your project.
And if this topic is new to you,
I encourage you to check out the Java
Script testing course here at Udacity.
For the purpose of this course,
we just assume that you know
the basics over learned in layout.
And thus we provided a sample
test suit as part of our sub lab.
Unit test, like Linton,
are here to prevent mistakes.
Wouldn't it be cool if you
could automate running them
just like everything else was set up so
far with our built.
Well there's one issue with that.
The unit test for your front end only
makes sense if they run in a browser.
Thus, running them from the terminal
environment won't do any good.
But this doesn't mean it's impossible,
it's just slightly more tricky.
Here's how it works.